في الحرب التي أطلقتها روسيا
ضد أوكرانيا ، عانت أماكن قليلة
أكثر من مجرد احتلال بوروديين من قبل
قوات فلاديمير بوتين منذ أواخر فبراير / شباط
واستعادها جناح الجيش الأوكراني مؤخرًا ، احتجزت يانكا من قبل الروس لفترة
طويلة جدًا ولمجرد إعطائك
فكرة عن  حجم الدمار
لديك مثل هذه المنازل التي
دمرت تمامًا ، ولكن إذا نظرنا
هنا يمكنك أن ترى أنه حتى
المباني السكنية الكبيرة قد
سويت بالأرض ، هذا المبنى بأكمله
كان متصلاً بهذا المبنى من
قبل ولكن الآن
لم يتبق شيء على الإطلاق
لقد حرص الروس على إظهار أنهم
يمتلكون هذه المدينة يرسمون الحرف v على
المباني المحتلة حتى أنه تم تشويه
إدارة مدينة
بورديانكا.
وعثرت على جنود روس
كانوا يقيمون في منزلهم ، تقول
إنهم نهبوا المكان
الكحول في كل مكان تقول إن
الزجاجات الفارغة في الردهة تحت الأشياء التي
دخنوها كثيرًا وأطفأوا السجائر على
المنضدة
، كما أظهروا لنا جثة رجل
عثروا عليه في فناء منزلهم الخلفي
، ويداه ورجلاه مقيدتان كدمات شديدة على جسده
غلاف صدفة لا يزال
تدعي روسيا القريبة أن قواتها لا تستهدف
المدنيين ، واصفة تقارير الفظائع
والاستفزازات المزيفة ،
لكن جامعي الجثث هؤلاء هم
الذين يتعين عليهم إزالة المذبحة التي
يتركها الجيش الروسي في أعقابها
في غضون أقل من ساعة
وجدوا شخصًا قتل بالرصاص.  أثناء ركوب
دراجة ، جسد محترق لدرجة يصعب التعرف
عليها ورجل لا يزال عالقًا في سيارته مصابًا
بثقوب الرصاص في رأسه
وصدره ، ويُعتقد أنه كان ينقل
الإمدادات الطبية المتناثرة الآن بالقرب من هذا
الطريق ، وأفظع شيء هو أن هؤلاء ليسوا
جنودًا مستلقين  هناك
أناس أبرياء فقط يقول غينادي بدون
سبب أسأل نعم بلا سبب
قتلوا وعذبوا بدون سبب
يقول الطريق من كييف إلى بورديان  كا محاط
بالقرى التي تضررت بشدة بعد
أن دمر الاحتلال الروسي الدبابات
والعربات المدرعة التي خلفتها وراءه ، ولكن هناك أيضًا
مؤشرات على مقدار القوة النارية
التي أطلقوها على هذه المنطقة ،
ويقول الروس إن هذه عملية خاصة وليست
حربًا وأنهم لا يؤذون المدنيين
ولكن  انظر إلى مقدار الذخيرة التي تركوها
وراءهم ببساطة في موقع إطلاق النار الفردي
هذا هنا ، فهذه ذخيرة
للأسلحة الثقيلة ذات الآثار المدمرة
على المناطق المدنية
التي يخترقها الدمار البلدات
والقرى شمال كييف حيث
يستمر عدد القتلى في الارتفاع الآن بعد
أن أصبح فلاديمير بوتين.
سحبت الجيوش قادة أوكرانيا ما زالوا
يعتقدون أنه يمكن دفن المزيد من الجثث
تحت الأنقاض المليئة
بالركام.